definamos algunos conjuntos digamos que
el conjunto a consta de los siguientes
elementos 13 5 7 18
el conjunto b que consta de reponerlo
con otro color
el conjunto b que consta de 1 718 y el
conjunto c que consta de 18 7
y 19 en este vídeo quiero revisar el
concepto de subconjunto y la pregunta es
el conjunto de es subconjunto de a y te
podrías preguntar qué es un subconjunto
bueno un conjunto subconjunto de otros y
todos los elementos de ese conjunto
también son elementos del otro conjunto
entonces podemos escribir que b
es un subconjunto y es de la anotación
para su conjunto b es un subconjunto de
a déjame escribir eso aquí abajo b es
subconjunto de a todos los elementos del
conjunto b también son elementos del
conjunto a podemos ser más precisos al
decir que ve es un subconjunto propio de
a pues b en su conjunto de a pero no es
igual a hay elementos en a que no están
en b podemos ser más precisos entonces y
decir que ve es un subconjunto propio o
subconjunto estricto de a denotamos eso
imaginando que esto es como el signo de
menor o igual por lo que tachamos la
línea de igual y así es como designamos
que ve su conjunto propio de a lo que
significa que todo elemento debe ese
elemento de a pero no todo elemento de a
ese elemento debe déjame escribir esto
aquí abajo entonces
es subconjunto propio o estricto también
por ejemplo podríamos escribir que a es
su conjunto de a de hecho cualquier
conjunto en su conjunto de sí mismo pues
todo elemento que está en a también está
en a lo que no podemos hacer es escribir
que a es subconjunto propio de a esto no
es cierto esto es falso bien hagamos
otro ejemplo podemos afirmar que b
es subconjunto
de sí podemos afirmar esto bueno veamos
uno está en c 715 18 este por lo cual
todos los elementos debe también son
elementos de c así es que esto es
verdadero ahora podemos afirmar que se
es subconjunto de a qué sé
es subconjunto
subconjunto de a
veamos cada elemento de se tiene que
estar en a tiene 18 a tiene 7 a tiene
uno pero a no tiene 19 por lo cual esto
de aquí de nueva cuenta es falso que no
es un conjunto de a en este caso que
hicimos aquí podemos escribir que ve es
un subconjunto de ese o inclusive que ve
es un subconjunto propio de c
ahora podemos invertir lo que escribimos
aquí y estaríamos entonces hablando de
súper conjuntos entonces al invertir
esta anotación
tendríamos que a
es un super conjunto
dv esta es otra manera de expresar que
ve en su conjunto de a pero cuando lo
escribimos así consideramos que a
contiene a todos los elementos que están
en be puede contener más elementos puede
contener exactamente los mismos
elementos esto aquí lo podías ver como
el símbolo de igual en el caso del mayor
o igual aunque no corresponde
exactamente a ese símbolo en este
sentido también podemos escribir que a
es un súper conjunto propio dv pues el
conjunto a tiene todos los elementos
debe e inclusive a tiene más elementos
no es exactamente equivalente a b espero
que a través de estos ejemplos te has
familiarizado con el concepto de
subconjuntos subconjuntos propios súper
conjuntos y súper conjuntos propios